a girl from will and grace came out and
said that
she has no idea why i would be chosen as
a host but it's like why do you care kim
kardashian is bringing the shade yep
during the premiere episode of her new
reality series the kardashians the
beauty mogul calls out the girl from
will and grace aka deborah messing for
questioning why she was picked to host
saturday night live why not but first
here's a little rewind back in september
when snl announced kim's new gig debra
shared her opinion on twitter asking why
kim kardashian i mean i know she is a
cultural icon but snl has hosts
generally who are performers who are
there to promote a film tv show or album
launch am i missing something you just
gotta roll with it but the will and
grace star's comment didn't roll with
kim's fans and deborah got some backlash
so she set the record straight with
tamron hall i was not uh intending to
troll her and um
you know if anybody took it that way uh
i apologize that was never my intention
she is this phenomenon you know she is a
cultural icon and they have had for
decades this sort of formula and i was
like oh does she have a new tv show
coming out does she have a book coming
out did she in a movie
and she didn't have anything coming out
actually her tv show had just wrapped
so i was just i was just confused and
that leads us back to the kardashians
premiere where the schemes founder
reacted to deborah's two cents listen
i'm the underdog everyone just thinks
i'm like a ditz the girl from will and
grace came out and said that
she has no idea why i would be chosen as
a host but it's like why do you care i
don't comment to tear people down
especially another female like if that's
what you think dude then like
cool
tune in the episodes are more a little
bit documentary style and i think that
you have a real insight into what the
girls are doing not only you know what
you see in the press or whatever but
what's really happening behind the
scenes and i love that some of the
journeys that all of them are on because
before you would see little snippets of
something and now i think the episodes
are fuller of content that shows the
whole story oh and by the way kim
totally nailed her snl debut she earned
rave reviews from critics and fans i
mean i'm married the best rapper of all
time
not only that he's the richest black man
in america a talented legit genius who
gave me four incredible kids
so when i divorced him you have to know
it came down to just one thing
his personality
and fans should expect to see more of
the mom of four's experience play out
this season including the kiss scene
round the world that sparked a romance
with pete davidson i like you just the
way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him he's just super
genuine and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and watch tv and
just do
nothing that's my favorite thing that's
the goal is finding someone to do
nothing with it's the best
[Music]
you